welcome to the free pilot training
channel on today's lesson we're going to
be talking about an important subject
special use airspace if you're new to
this channel and you're looking for free
private pilot ground study material
consider starting with lesson one i'll
throw a link right here to that playlist
if you want to check it out
let's get started in the simplest terms
special use airspace is airspace that
can contain hazardous activities
because of this we need to know the
rules and the limits of this airspace
and how to identify it there are six
types of special use
airspace prohibited areas restricted
areas
warning areas moas alert areas
and cfas prohibited areas are strictly
prohibited to aircraft
that's because of security or national
welfare these areas are labeled with a p
followed by a number and that's how you
can look up the details in the federal
register or the aeronautical charts
let's take a look at a prohibited area
near
amarillo the first thing you should
notice here is this blue hatched area
that's going to let you know that
there's some special used airspace here
now take a look here at the label p47
if you want to find out some more
information about this prohibited area
flip over to the back of your vfr
sectional
by the way you can get free digital
copies of all the latest vfr sectionals
from the faa's website
i'll put a link in the description if
you want to download some of those
okay so now that we've flipped it over
to the back take a look here at this
line labeled p47 as you can see it
starts at the surface and goes up to
then here in the time of use it's
continuous that means there's never a
time you can fly through it
now if you'll notice there's no
controlling agency or frequency to
contact someone on
and that's because there's never going
to be a time when you're allowed to go
in there
if there were a controlling agency or a
frequency on there
there's a tiny chance you could get
permission to go through that airspace
now let's talk about restricted areas
for just a minute
these areas aren't necessarily
prohibited but they can be very
hazardous to aircraft that are not
participating in the activities
happening in that airspace
these can often be unusual and even
invisible to pilots
these can include artillery firing
aerial gunnery guided missiles or much
more
the most important thing for you to
remember today about restricted areas is
that you're not allowed to enter these
unless you're
cleared to enter or the area is not
active
let's take a look and see how we can
tell if the area is active or not
take a look at this restricted area if
you'll notice it's marked a lot like the
prohibited areas we saw earlier
now if you look a little bit closer
you'll notice that there's actually
quite a few of these in this one spot
here
but today we're going to focus on
restricted area 5601 alpha
okay so let's flip back over to the back
of our vfr sectional
the first thing i notice when i find
alpha on this chart here is that alpha
bravo and charlie are operated together
and you can see that all three of these
areas start at the surface and go up to
four
zero thousand msl it looks like all
these areas are constantly active too
but check this out 5601 juliet is only
active from sunrise to 2200 local
on monday through friday then check out
this little cross right here
that means it's activated by nodum too
so as long as we're outside of these
times and the nodems don't show it
activated we can fly through 5601 juliet
and we don't even have to ask permission
but if we do want to try to go in there
while these areas are activated
we need to contact the controlling
agencies listed here
in this case it's fort worth center and
you can see that we contact them on
128.4 or
133.5 just ignore these frequencies that
are larger than 224 these are military
uhf frequencies okay so just to be clear
because you might see this on the test
for restricted areas you can enter them
as long as you either have permission
or the area is not active just keep that
in mind
warning areas are really similar to
restricted areas and that there's a lot
of hazardous activities going on in
these areas as well
but the us government doesn't have sole
jurisdiction in these areas so they
can't keep you from entering
check out these warning areas in the
gulf just west of miami
typically you'll find that warning areas
start at three nautical miles or more
from the coast and extend out towards
domestic or international waters
because of this the faa doesn't have
jurisdiction in these areas and you can
fly your 152 in there anytime you want
but do you really think that's a good
idea with all the craziness going on in
these areas
but if you do want to fly safely into
warning areas check the back of your bfr
sectional
just like we did in the restricted areas
then if they are active
contact the appropriate controlling
agency to make sure it's safe to go in
there
next let's take a look at something
called military operations areas or moas
you can identify these by these hatched
magenta lines like you see here
in these areas there can be a lot of
military activities that's not quite as
hazardous as what you'd see in a warning
area or in a restricted area
but these areas can still be really
dangerous because military pilots can be
performing some really high speed
maneuvers in these areas
in fact the military allows their pilots
to fly faster in these areas
than is typically allowed below 10 000
feet because of this
atc typically routes ifr traffic around
active moas
in fact mows were designed to keep ifr
traffic separated from these guys
that being said vfr pilots can fly
through these areas even when they're
active
without permission if you do this though
i would be very careful and keep your
eyes outside the whole time
when it comes to moas sometimes you'll
find information about them inside or
around their airspace
you can find the rest of the information
on the back of the vfr sectional
just like on the restricted areas the
warning areas and the prohibited areas
now while you're legally not required to
do so if you're going to fly through a
moa i really recommend checking to make
sure that the mode is not active first
and if it is active i really recommend
contacting the controlling agency before
entering
those guys are not always watching for
your piper cub when they're playing war
alert areas are really similar to moe's
because in these areas you'll find a
high volume of pilot training or an
unusual type of aerial activity
check out this airspace surrounding
vance air force base
as you can see we have the same hashed
magenta lines
now we can see that it's an alert area
by the a preceding the number
now we can look here to see that this
alert area is because of high density
student training
just like moas you can fly through these
areas even when they're active without
permission
but do you really think that's a good
idea with brand new air force pilots
flying high performance aircraft through
this airspace
personally i would either go around or
contact vance approach before entering
last thing we'll talk about today is
controlled firing areas or cfas
these areas contain activities that if
not conducted in a controlled
environment
could be hazardous to non-participating
aircraft but these areas are not charted
and the hazardous activities should stop
if your aircraft gets too close
when these areas are active typically
they'll have some kind of ground
spotters
spotting aircraft or some kind of radar
to keep track of airplanes coming into
the area
and just like a pedestrian at a
crosswalk they have to stop firing for
you
but it's good to be aware that areas
like this exist
hey i hope you enjoyed today's training
before you leave here please be sure to
drop down and hit that like button for
me
and if you haven't already be sure to
check out the other great training i
have available
i promise you it's going to help you on
your written test and your check ride
i'll see you in the next episode